هذا هو الجزء من هذا البالون الذي
يريد المحققون أن يضعوا أيديهم على
هذه الحمولة النافعة مركزًا مركزيًا وما
بدا وكأنه صفيفتان شمسيتان على
كلا الجانبين عندما تم
تدمير البالون ، يمكنك رؤيته
يسقط بعيدًا الآن إذا كان هذا يحتوي على
كتلة إنسان مثل لاعب القفز بالمظلات ، فقد
تسقط بسرعة 150 ميلاً في الساعة أو
شيء من هذا القبيل إذا كان لديها كتلة
من سيارتين ،
فربما تكون سرعتها النهائية أكثر من 500
ميل في الساعة أو أكثر مما
يعنيه ذلك  عندما تصل إلى هذه المنطقة
قبالة شاطئ ميرتل مباشرة ، ستكون المياه في
الأساس مثل الخرسانة ، فإنها
ستضربها بقوة هائلة وستكون مشوهة
تمامًا وممزقة
بسبب هذا التأثير ، ما الذي يعنيه
استرداد ما يعنيه هو أول
شيء  يتعين عليهم القيام به عندما
يستقرون هناك ، هناك الحصول على غواصين على عمق 47
قدمًا ، وهذا أمر جيد وهذا
عمق عملي جيد هناك ، وعليهم أن ينظروا
إلى هذا الرقم لمعرفة عدد القطع الموجودة
في المكان الذي يتم تقييمه فيه ، ومعرفة ما
إذا كان بعضها خاليًا  مدفونًا في
الوحل أدناه ثم وضع قائمة
بالأولويات ، ما الذي يريدون
طرحه أولاً ، كيف يريدون طرحه
لحماية كل هذا قدر
الإمكان وإلى متى ستستغرق
هذه العمليات  عادة ما تكون أطول
مما يتوقعه معظم الناس على الرغم من أنهم
يعتقدون أن هذا يمكن أن يكون سريعًا جدًا ،
فكر في الأمر بهذه الطريقة ، هذا يشبه
مسرح الجريمة تحت الماء الآن وعليهم
حماية أدلتهم بأفضل ما
يمكن إذا كانوا يريدون معرفة كل ما
في وسعهم.  هذا البالون